und auf einmal kam ein Getrampel ein
Getöse von dem Wagen zwei es verführt
sich laut geworden Schrei durcheinander
hilfe hilfe weg weg weg und dann auch
die schreien noch das Täters du bist
komplett woanders der interessiert kein
Geschäft mehr kein Geld mehr das ist so
weit weg auf einmal was einfach nur ein
riesen riesen Glück gehabt hast dass der
nicht auf uns losgehen weil wir werden
den nächsten gewissen der war kurz davor
ja Meter 50 Meter bei der vor mir
gestanden ist war einfach er war
komplett voll Blut also die Arme und der
Oberkörper war komplett voll Blut und es
ging aber so schnell dann dass der
Koffer flog und ich das dann immer
mitbekommen habe weil ich eigentlich
noch daraus gerannt bin das war der
Hintergrund ist
Regionalexpress 70 fährt im Bahnhof von
Brokstedt bei Neumünster ein im Zug
spielen sich zu dieser Zeit bereits
dramatisches Szenen ab wenige Minuten
zuvor hat ein Mann unvermittelt ein
Messer gezogen und angefangen auf die
Fahrgäste einzustechen Christian Götzner
ist einer der rund 200 Passagiere der
Geschäftsmann aus Bayern sitzt einen
Wagen vom Angreifer entfernt als der
Mann mit dem Messer in seine Richtung
kommt fliehen er und viele weitere
Passagiere in ein kleines Waldstück
neben dem Bahnhof
gesprochen die war so ungefähr 20 das
hassen neben mir und die haben jetzt die
stand direkt neben ihm so die stand
richtig neben ihm da ist eingestiegen an
der Tasche
extrem nervös hat sie mir erzählt und
auf einmal hat er das Messer rausgezogen
und dann ist sie gelaufen
gar nichts einfach Messer rausgezogen
das geht in unserem Kopf vor warum macht
er das jetzt oder irgendwann Hass auf
uns auf Deutschland auf die Behörden
sechs Tage zuvor wird der mutmaßliche
Angreifer Ibrahim a aus der
Justizvollzugsanstalt Billwerder in
Hamburg entlassen ein Gericht der
Hansestadt hatte den Haftbefehl gegen
den Palästinenser ohne
Staatsangehörigkeit aufgehoben der
33-Jährige hatte wegen Körperverletzung
und einem Einspruch gegen das Urteil
bereits ein Jahr in Untersuchungshaft
verbracht die restlichen 7 Tage
Gefängnis muss er nicht mehr antreten
2015 kam Ibrahim a nach Deutschland in
Nordrhein-Westfalen wird er in den
kommenden fünf Jahren dreimal
rechtskräftig verurteilt
2021 sucht er sich eine Unterkunft in
Kiel
nach der Haftentlassung muss er seine
duldungsbescheinigung verlängern er
spricht so vieles bislang bekannt am Tag
in Kiel bei zwei Behörden vor beide Male
ist die Verständigung schwierig im neuen
und im Alten Rathaus der Stadt wird ihm
erklärt dass er eine Meldebestätigung
brauche seine gerade abgelaufene
Haftstrafe ist anscheinend beide kein
Thema
also die Vorschrift ist wenn die
Staatsanwaltschaft fangen wir mal an
eine Ermittlungsverfahren einleitet
gegen eine ausländischen Mitbürger muss
sie die Ausländerbehörde informieren das
ist die Gesetzeslage und in einer
perfekten Welt würde die
Staatsanwaltschaft einfach ein Häkchen
ein Programm machen und automatisch
würden diese Daten drüber laufen das
funktioniert aber nicht was keine
Schnittstellen der Ausländerämter zur
Staatsanwaltschaft gibt also muss der
arme Staatsanwalt ein Brief selber
aufsetzen und diesen Brief per Post an
die Ausländerbehörde schicken der mit
dort diese Information ankommt dann gibt
es sozusagen teilautomatisiert dieses
System die den Brief immerhin
automatisch generieren aber trotzdem ist
es noch ein Brief der auf dem Postweg
zugestellt wird und das ist natürlich
ein sehr sehr langsames und auch nicht
sehr zuverlässiges Verfahren und
deswegen ist es eben nicht nur ein
Einzelfall mit der tragischen Ausgang
sondern ganz generell ist die
Kommunikation zwischen Justiz und zum
Beispiel auseinanderbehörden stark
verbesserungsfähig
mehr als 200 verschiedene
behördenregister gibt es in Deutschland
es gibt kaum gemeinsame Schnittstellen
im Fall von Ibrahim a verschickte
Hamburg E-Mails mit Informationen für
die Ausländerbehörde in Kiel ob die
gelesen wurden fragte niemanden nach
natürlich hängt genau dieser Art von
Datenaustausch dann davon ab dass die
richtige Person auch tatsächlich
aufmerksam ist und wir wollen natürlich
nicht dass es an der Schusseligkeit
einzelner Menschen am Ende liegt ob am
Ende Verbrechen verhindert werden können
klar ist niemand hätte in Kiel ahnen
können wieder weitere Tag von Ibrahim a
verläuft niemandem ist irgendetwas
ungewöhnliches aufgefallen weder im
neuen noch im alten Rathaus beide Male
schicken die Mitarbeiter Ihnen zur
zentralen Beratungsstelle für
wohnungslose Männer um eine
Meldebestätigung zu erfragen die
Einrichtung aber hat bereits geschlossen
als er dort eintrifft vielleicht ist
dieser dritte erfolglose Behördengang
einer zu viel Ibrahim a fährt in den
einzigen Supermarkt den er aus seiner
Kieler Zeit gut kennt und kauft sich ein
Messer
am Kieler Hauptbahnhof besteigt der
einen ICE nach Hamburg in Neumünster
aber wirft ihn der Schaffner raus er
hatte keine Fahrkarte erst dort steigt
Ibrahim a in den Regionalexpress 70
Richtung Hamburg
er verletzt eine 17-jährige Schülerin
und eine 19-Jährigen Auszubildenden
tödlich 5 weitere Fahrgäste werden zum
Teil schwer verletzt im Innen und
Rechtsausschuss des Landtages von
Schleswig-Holstein wird ein Vertreter
des Bundesministeriums für Migration und
Flüchtlinge später sagen dass Ibrahima
vermutlich keinen Schutzstatus erhalten
hätte wäre der Strafverfahren gegen ihn
bekannt gewesen
generell sind behördenfrei in ihrer
Kommunikation miteinander also kein
telefoniert man kann Brief schreiben man
kann auch immer noch ein Fax schicken
dann ist es immerhin so dass man E-Mail
schreiben darf also dass die E-Mail als
komplikationsweg anerkannt ist und an
sich werden in diesem Fall
wahrscheinlich auch ganz normale E-Mails
geschrieben dann gibt es aber die
Übermittlung besonders sensibler Daten
das können das Besondere
Gesundheitsdaten sein oder Daten z.B im
sozialkontext diese Daten müssen Ende zu
Ende verschlüsselt werden und das
wiederum setzt die Fähigkeit von beiden
also dem Absender den Empfänger aus
E-Mails verschlüsselt zu versenden und
verschlüsselt zu empfangen
doch offensichtlich fließt der Inhalt
der E-Mails nicht in die ausländerakte
von Ibrahim a ein im Innen- und
Rechtsausschuss heißt es die Mails sind
im Spam-Filter gelandet oder wurden
übersehen wieso Behörden für Ihre
Kommunikation nicht mindestens
e-mail-assistenten oder absenderfilter
verwenden ist Experten ein Rätsel
jeder der E-Mails nutzt oder
E-Mail-Programm benutzt oder auch nur
ein Webdienstleister benutzt für seine
E-Mails der weiß eigentlich wenn ich
viele Nachrichten bekomme dann macht es
immer Sinn mit den sogenannten Regeln zu
arbeiten das ist ganz einfach das heißt
eigentlich wenn wenn eine Mail von
diesem Absender kommt dann sorge dafür
dass es immer in folgendem Ordner landet
das ist die einfachste Möglichkeit einer
Sortierung und die kann jeder und die
können sicherlich auch Ämter umsetzen
und die arbeiten ja auch mit E-Mail
Programm die noch weitaus mehr Filter
Möglichkeiten erlauben und wenn ich mit
sehr sehr vielen Nachrichten tatsächlich
tagtäglich umgehen muss dann muss man
auch noch auf vielleicht
professionellere Systeme umschwenken
Dokumentenmanagement Systeme und die
gibt es zu Hause und die kann man auch
nutzen
[Musik]
erst durch digitale Nachforschungen
kommt heraus die Mails der Hamburger
Justizbehörde sind in Kiel angekommen
die Informationen über Ibrahim a lagen
vor die Hinweise auf seine Haftstrafe
und die Entlassungen Hamburg hatte aber
noch niemand gelesen im konkreten Fall
allerdings hätte das nichts geändert
niemand greift am Tag in Kiel auf seine
Akte zu
in einer gut digitalisierten Welt gäbe
es eine digitale Schnittstelle der
Ausländerbehörde zur Staatsanwaltschaft
oder zur Justiz und dann würde
eigentlich automatisch ein
Datenaustausch generiert der sagt in dem
Moment wo jemand freigelassen wird oder
ein Verfahren eingeleitet wird
informiere ich die Ausländerbehörde ohne
dass ein Mensch noch was tun muss ihm
automatisch über diesen
Gesamtbild von Ibrahim a gibt es vor der
Tat nicht nach und nach wird bekannt
anscheinend hat er ein Drogenproblem er
selbst behauptet Stimmen zu hören eine
psychologische Untersuchung des ordnet
weder die justizin NRW noch in Hamburg
an
Christian Götzner hat viel Glück gehabt
Ibrahim a stand bereits vor ihm als ein
anderer Passagier seinen Koffer auf den
Angreifer wirft und den Täter stockt
die Tat hinterlässt Spuren
[Musik]
das ist vollkommen unterschiedlich mal
Woche nachts auftragen davon gestern
habe ganze blöds ergeben das gehabt da
bin ich auch wieder diesen regiozug
gefahren aber nicht in der oben sondern
woanders aber den gleichen Zugtyp das
erste mal wieder nach dieser Tat und das
war ein extrem mulmiges Gefühl aber wie
gehen wir damit um den Alltag so normal
wieder zu leben das geht ich arbeite
wieder sehr viel habe eine sehr gute
Unterstützung durch meine Frau
und doch meine Kinder und das ist
eigentlich
wieder ganz in Ordnung auch wieder zu
Kreis auch wieder also diese Vermeidung
Strategie habe ich nicht das ist kein
Zufall das habe ich nicht
aber mit dem Regio zu gestern das war
einfach
sehr sehr ungewohnt
Ibrahim a sitzt derzeit in
Untersuchungshaft in Neumünster die
Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt noch auch
was vor der Messe Attacke in
Regionalexpress 70 passieren die für
Ibrahim a zuständige Ausländerbehörde
wurde über die Ermittlungen informiert
ganz nach geltender Vorschrift per
Briefpost